are there books
and movies in your life long ago or
recently that had a big impact on you
uh yeah the main one is about face
which is sitting right here there you go
this is written by colonel david
hackworth it's the
book that really had a massive impact on
me from a leadership perspective
and i ended up i talked about it enough
that it started kind of coming back and
started selling well and
they contacted me and i wrote a forward
for it so that book had a huge impact on
me
and i still when i read it
i still get lessons out of it just about
every time this is a vietnam war
and korea and korea and he
got in towards the end of right at the
end of world war ii
so he was kind of raised by the the
soldiers that fought
in world war ii and then he went to
korea and then he went to vietnam
an exceptional warrior a soldier soldier
if you can give a little inkling what
made him a soldier soldier
so i he died in 2005.
so i never got to meet him and
i i had a guy on my podcast who worked
for him
in vietnam a guy named general
james mukayama and luckily his son
had reached out to me and said
i think you're talking about my dad
because i read some passage in there
that
that jim mukayama was young young
captain jim mukayam a company commander
in vietnam
he said i think you're talking about my
dad
would you want to talk to him and i said
absolutely well here's the thing that i
didn't really understand and you read
one quote but there's all these quotes
in that book
that talk about how great hackworth was
and
what an incredible leader he was and how
he was the best combat leader anyone
ever seen and all these just really
complimentary things that are
said by a bunch of different people and
when you read the book
you're reading this guy's account of
what he went through
but i never really knew if that was all
true or did he just cherry-pick his
friends
quotes about him and cherry-pick the
stories that he wanted to tell
and so it was very interesting for me
when i met mukayam
general mukuyama who he became a general
eventually when i met him
and we were talking about his life and i
was very curious and i was a little bit
nervous going into this interview
because i was thinking
maybe my hero my mentor this guy that
i've never met before
maybe he's just an arrogant jerk that
talked
talked himself up in this book so i'm
sitting down with with general mukuyama
and i finally got to the part where he's
meeting
hackworth for the first time and
i said did you know did you know who
hackworth was
when he showed up so he was mooc they
call him mook mook was the
was the like the adjutant to the
to the general that that was going to
that hackworth was going to be working
for
so when hackworth comes into the office
the first person he meets is this guy
this guy cap mokiyama and so hackworth
walks in and i said when hackworth
walked in
did you know who he was and mukayama
says
everybody knew who he was mr infantry
and so he ended up explaining that
everything that is written in there
about hackworth
they they just loved him they adored him
up the chain of command it turned out a
little bit different and
you know the title of the book is about
face and if you're familiar familiar
with
military drill about faces when you turn
around 180 degrees
and at the end of the vietnam war
towards the end of the vietnam war
he was so disgusted with the way that
the war was being
fought he was so disgusted with the
decisions that were being made by the
leadership
that he did an interview he was the
first colonel
first senior officer to do an interview
that
spoke out against the war that was
happening and this is while he's in
vietnam by the way
so he got drummed out of the army and he
was forced to retire and that was that
so there's an element of rebelliousness
to him
and you know when you talk to me about
are
are there times when the leader is
making the leadership this
absolute senior leadership the civilian
leadership is doing the wrong things yes
and there's times when people speak out
against it
and there's an argument for against that
too even even with hackworth
you know did he when you get when you
quit your job or you do something that
gets you fired which is what he did
you immediately give up all your
influence over what's happening
so they get another they get another
battalion commander to take his place
they get another colonel to step in and
take his place that's what they do
and now he can't help anymore he can't
help his troops
but at that point in the war he loved
his men so much
that he was sickened with the
situation on the ground and he and he
spoke out about it
so that book had a huge impact on me and
like i said i still i still read it all
the time
i reread it all the time and i always
take lessons from it
you